[Music]
imagine traveling at the speed of an
airplane but on ground level and in a
giant tube that's the idea behind the
Hyperloop a network of incredibly
fast-moving pods that can carry
passengers to destinations all over the
world reducing travel times from hours
to minutes but how would that work would
it be safe and what would it be like to
ride in one of these pods this is what
if and here's what would happen if earth
had a global Hyperloop Network a
Hyperloop consists of pods that travel
through pressurized tubes using
electromagnetic propulsion this may
sound like the stuff of science fiction
but several companies are surprisingly
close to making it a safe viable reality
once completed this giant transportation
system would connect all major cities
around the globe how would it change the
way we live our lives if all goes
according to plan a Hyperloop system
would be cheaper faster and more
environmentally friendly than planes
trains and automobiles the first ones
would be built on a relatively small
scale covering shorter journeys like Los
Angeles to San Francisco traveling at
over 1,200 kilometers per hour these
speedy pods would take the pressure off
gridlocked roads making travel between
cities much easier for everyone
populations would have the ability to
spread out further from city centers
since faster travel times would mean
people aren't forced to live where their
jobs are located we'd also have a lot
more time to be productive because we
wouldn't waste as much of our days
getting to where we needed to go but the
real exciting prospects of a Hyperloop
come into play when you look at it on a
global scale first off international
travel would become a whole lot more
accessible Elon Musk one of the founders
of the project says that tickets would
be kept affordable in order to open the
service up to everyone on top of that
international deliveries would be
completely revolutionized with the
Hyperloop we could autonomously ship
packages across the world at the cost of
trucking and the speed of flight
before we get too far ahead of ourselves
with all the possibilities what would it
be like to ride the thing well for one
thing the pods would be pretty small
they'd have to be narrowed to travel at
such high speeds so things might get a
little cramped and you wouldn't have any
windows instead there would be augmented
reality screens that can simulate
scenery or provide entertainment but the
seats would be comfortable and that's a
big deal considering how intense the
ride gets the designers behind the
Hyperloop say that riders would only
experience unease during the
acceleration and deceleration of the
trip a span of only about two minutes
but what about when it turns have you
ever made a sharp turn in your car at 50
kilometres an hour we'll imagine what
that would be like at 1200 km/h one way
to smooth it out would be to make huge
curves in the track to make long gradual
turns but that would make for a much
larger impact on the areas the tunnels
run through and what if it needed to
make an emergency stop a sudden halt at
these speeds would be ten times worse
than a car crash at 110 km/h these
concerning questions
coupled with the obvious issues that
would come with building giant tunnels
that span across oceans and numerous
governments are signs that the Hyperloop
might just be a fantasy for now in the
meantime maybe someone will come up with
a better idea for rapid global transit
but that's a topic for another what-if
[Music]